foreign
[Music]
the cancer is still spreading I'm afraid
there's nothing else we can do there is
one person who might be able to help our
program is a two-pronged treatment
outside Mexico City the results have
been stunning she saved my life
you're in very good hands with us
after that what happens then your whole
John Kramer
according to these scans the tumor was
never removed how much time do I have
months at best I still have a lot of
work that needs to be done
[Music]
hello everyone it's time to play a game
we all pretended to cure me but what I
have planned for each of you is very
real
foreign
but trust me
you will want to remain alert
[Music]
of all the men to cheat you picked John
Kramer please don't hesitate place a big
enough piece of yours or you roll tissue
into the glass enzyme tank this will
save your life
I don't
know
this is not retribution it's a
Reawakening
[Music]
little dog the choice is yours
foreign
[Music]